and of course what it all clarified was
the fact that the
antifa activists are have a very clear
policy which is that they want to
provoke
the police or need any law enforcement
into something they can pretend is an
act of violence that they can catch on
camera and use
as an explanation for the allegedly
fascist nature of the american state
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report joining me today is a
best-selling author
political pundit and now american
cultural
expert douglas murray douglas welcome to
the reuben report
it's a great pleasure to be back with
you dave do you consider yourself an
american
cultural expert now that you spent how
long about two months traversing
our great country seeing cities burn and
going to joyous rallies and everything
in between are you a cultural
expert of americana if i am then there's
hundreds of millions of others as well
uh and it certainly does feel like that
sometimes
i do notice that many millions of
cultural experts on america
uh don't bother by going there at all
um and don't bother traveling around but
but yeah i mean i spent a very very
interesting period
ahead of the election as you know
traveling all around your country to the
extent that you can in these days
uh went across about six or seven states
and was there right up until just after
the election i spent the election in
washington dc yeah so i thought you'd be
the right guy to talk to for my post
thanksgiving show because i thought we
could get away a little bit from like
the minutia of american politics but i
think getting your perspective as an
outsider that spent so much time here
um and that that has you know a cohesive
world view so
i thought we'd start by saying so when
you were here about
six weeks ago or so we actually went out
to lunch one day and we were just
heading back we were heading back to my
place
and we saw a trump rally in beverly
hills we did not know
that there was a trump rally but we got
out of the car and we thought all right
let's do a little
exploration and see what's what uh i
think at this point my audience knows my
take on it what
what was your take on that rally and
then subsequently you went to a bunch of
others and got to see some stuff
yes i mean i wanted to get a sense of
where america was ahead of the election
i was writing from
multiple states from new york long
island
to california to oregon uh
to atlanta georgia pensacola florida
washington dc i did quite a good round
and one of the purposes of it really was
to try to get a
sense of the temperature in america at
the moment i have been in the country
for a couple of years
i've traveled there a lot in my life but
i noticed quite a lot of things that
seemed new to me
or at least worse to me and as for that
particular day i mean it was
that was an interesting thing was it
because i thought
well la was an unlikely place
to stumble across a pro-trump rally i
thought it was
very good-natured and uh and diverse to
use the most important word of the era
uh and and i suppose the other thing
that struck me was something else that
i noticed in other places across my
travels which was that
um i i actually predicted ahead of the
election i didn't know how it was going
to go but i did say ahead of the
election that i thought that there was a
quiet trump
vote one might even say an embarrassed
trump vote to some is likely to
to signify something at the polls
uh and one of the things was it was only
one of the examples but was yes the fact
that i think that day
about what about one day everyone in
every two cars i'd have thought
was beeping support for that rally
in l.a and i thought that was that was
striking
um and i found i found a certain amount
of other that sort of
you know quiet trump voter in in
california
uh so so yeah it was it was one it was
what it was one sort of
piconet example of something that was
definitely going on
was it sort of doubly surprising because
you know as someone that's a a media
creature
and you know how the media operates and
everything else
to see it on the ground and just how
sort of different it was i mean you said
the diversity word but i mean
truly there were they were blacks for
trump and asians for trump and jews for
trump and christians were trump and gays
for trump
did that still shock you even though
maybe you know that the media doesn't
report on this in the in the most
totally honest way
no i'm i'm quite hard to shock
and it can be done but it takes an awful
lot of effort
um and i i know i had i had i had
assumed that
a lot of people were finding their own
way for themselves uh
my own experience in uh the last few
years in multiple countries has been
that
there are things that the media say and
they bang on at and
they still don't they still don't impact
individuals who
can come to their own decisions
particularly in our era where they can
find their own
sources of information and find their
own groups of
like-minded people and and see through
certain myths that are told so
i wasn't i wasn't surprised at that at
the rally in pensacola florida i went to
which is a much bigger affair of course
thousands and thousands of people
um one of many things that struck me was
the good
naturedness of the crowd and of course
that is something which
um which which doesn't come across in
almost any press coverage which presents
the president's rallies as being um
rather hate-filled affairs and
irrespective of whatever he says from
the podium
and i can't deny that i mean being a
member of the press when he starts to
sort of point to that when he pointed to
the press gallery and started saying
the lying press and everyone started
booing um i suppose
you know still part of my my hackles go
up
at that um but you know i told
i was i was there as a member of the
audience i signed up as an attendee
and was right in the heart of it making
notes clearly a member of the president
introducing myself as a journalist
and was treated only with courtesy and
and uh
um and you know and kindness by the
attendees so there was no
there was no sort of you know unpleasant
undertone or anything like that yeah
so you left los angeles i said goodbye
to you and you said i'm going to
portland
and i said why are you going to portland
and i think you said
i need to see it for myself so you went
up to portland
what do you see up in portland
i slightly shot my bolt on this because
i wrote a piece for one of the papers
saying california's if california is a
failed state
and then i went to oregon
um yeah yeah um
portland is some people say to me you
know why do you need to go and see this
stuff for yourself and i just think it's
it's an instinctive curiosity i have and
i also
even when it is exactly what you think
it is going to be
it's still interesting you know
portland oregon was exactly what i
feared it would be but a bit worse
i was horrified by the immigration of
the city
the total destruction of all public
monuments and public buildings
the shuttering up of shops intimidation
of the citizenry
the demoralization of the citizenry uh a
homelessness problem which makes even
california's look minimal
um and the fact that the city's
basically been given over
to uh an immigrated lawlessness
i went with antifa
several nights in a row uh to
pardon the language a
gentrification protest
which was my first yeah that was your
first one
yeah it was yes i've heard the two
always avoided the temptation
i i quite like gentrification actually i
think i think that
houses being made nicer and neighborhood
being smarter is no bad thing but
old-fashioned view uh certainly not the
viewer of antifa in portland who
sectioned off some of the streets and
went through them in the middle of the
night
screaming at the citizens and the house
owners telling them they were all stay
on stolen land this included many black
families by the way
uh shouting at these black families
white families families of every
background
shouting at them they were on stolen
land and um
and should get out were you worried were
you worried for your own safety i mean
you were you were out there with them i
mean
people know who you are yes i was
um lucky enough in the era of mask
wearing you can cover almost your entire
face uh lawfully indeed almost
compulsively
and um i was uh
i mean i've been in worse places and war
zones where
there's more lawlessness than that but i
i
it was not in a pleasant situation to be
in in what is nominally a first world
city
um the second night i went with them to
the protest of the ice facility where um
which was a bit hairier because they
were assaulting the city's one the very
few
um federal buildings in the in the area
uh they play a game of cat and mouse
with law enforcement
they get closer and closer to the front
of the building their aim in the past
has been to barricade in the buildings
put burning dumpster trucks in front of
them and then kill the people inside by
burning them
alive so that's their modus operandi so
you can understand why the ice officers
don't want that
and they get within a certain uh
closeness to the door
and then the uh officers break out and
uh there was firing tear gas uh pepper
bullets
and all that were and people were
selling fire things in the street
and uh and that was that was uh
unpleasant yes
i got um
you know shoot out of an alleyway
by federal officers with a bunch of
other antifa with me and um
the officers at gunpoint you know told
us please to move
out of the alleyway and it was
unpleasant but i have to say that
considering the situation i thought the
officers were as as decent and
reasonable and efficient in their duties
as they could possibly be
and of course what it all clarified was
the fact that
the antifa activists
are have a very clear policy which is
that they want to provoke
the police or need any law enforcement
into something they can pretend
is an act of violence that they can
catch on camera and use as an
explanation for the allegedly fascist
nature of the american state
they are it was very interesting to see
these activists up close
i thought they were all um reprehensible
people i thought they were clearly
mentally in a very unstable place
i thought that furthermore on election
night in washington dc when i saw antifa
um gathering in the doorways just
outside the north lawn of the white
house the world's press were pointing
their cameras at the white house
and beside them underneath some of the
doorways i saw what was clearly anti for
gathering because they
were changing into clothes so that they
couldn't be recognized by
cctv cameras uh went over to
film this because it was clear this was
what was going on and they became very
violent very fast
and uh they are thugs they're a
paramilitary group
they have no place in a democracy um
it's to america's shame that they've
been allowed to do
what they have been doing they
threatened to kill journalists
they had graffitied kill andy no
mutual friend and uh journalist and
reporter in portland oregon
they had graffitied calls to murder him
across
the city um uh the fact that they can
then intimidate a journalist
from abroad who even has the tama the
tenacity
to try to catch them on a video camera
or
look at what they're doing is very bad
it's an embarrassment for america i
think the whole thing's an embarrassment
did you get a sense that when you're on
the ground with him that there
is a leader because you know this is
what joe biden described antifa as an
idea
and partly what i think it seems to be
is that there's no
sort of known leader sort of by design
but when you're out there with these
groups dc portland wherever you are
could you sense like oh somebody's
actually in charge or is it just like
this roving gang yeah
no of course they have a leadership uh
andy knows forthcoming book will reveal
a lot about this
um but yes of course they have a
leadership uh
they don't gather like uh moisture or
something i mean it's
uh they are brought together they are
organized
they advertise within their own groups
what they're going to do and when what
their actions are they tell people
what to bring or what not to bring what
to say and what not to say what to chant
and what not to chant and uh
and yeah i mean they they they do the
whole thing they're an organized group
and by the way one of the one of the
most haunting things for me was
uh i mean i i'm among others i
interviewed lots of people on my travels
including
black police officers in oregon who i
think were some of the most
the bravest most remarkable and i
thought
um restrained people i've ever met
but one of the conversations that
haunted me even more than that
was speaking to an owner of a restaurant
in
a cafe in portland who had
just recently had just the day before
had had bullets
live ammunition but it's fired through
the windows of his his
business because he it seemed because
he has photos on the wall of um first
responders
a woman a woman soldier a u.s
soldier a man in fireman's uniform
and this apparently makes him a
representative of the fascistic
american state thus live ammunition is
fired by antifa blm activists through
his business
uh by the way he is a is a black
american a very proud patriot
and he said to me actually we talked
about this i said to him
you know what do you think of the uh of
the them
presidential contender joe biden's claim
that it's just an idea
and he pointed to the bullet holes in
his business his windows and he said but
an idea doesn't fire bullets
um i mean that's it so yeah so
what was your main takeaway now that now
that you've left our shores you you got
to see
sort of the bipolar nature of america
we're still in this sort of election
limbo
at the moment you know millions of
people did not celebrate thanksgiving
with their
families because of covid and everything
else or the law i should say the
lockdowns more than covid specifically
um what's your diagnosis of of what
we're going through here
oh i think you're in real trouble i
think you're in
real trouble um
all countries are some extent i mean we
all have the coveted
layer on top of everything else and the
financial catastrophe that it
constitutes
uh my own country's gotta find a way to
pay for something like 210 billion
pounds spent so far this year in the
in the covid era these sorts of sums are
very hard to recoup in taxation without
crippling your economy afterwards
we've all got a lot of trouble and we
have this
very testing year we're all in still in
with lockdowns and inability to see our
loved ones
um because of a virus that is serious
but i think
in my own estimation not as bad as the
thing we thought it was at the outset
um and there will be a long period of
people arguing over the uh
whether we overreacted or not with this
virus
but all of these things in a way seem to
reveal
underlying problems in the society as
well i've been struck may i say that
in my own country there was a period of
political unity at the beginning of the
corona
era we unified as a country around
our health service our prime minister
specifically around
the queen and it was it was a very
moving thing actually because we'd said
for years in britain we
had no societal trust and no points of
unity and actually
i thought we did have some we've lost
some of it since perhaps inevitably
um but we did have stores of of trust
and
unity the one country in the world i
know of where that just didn't last
and a second was america because of the
nature of the trump presidency because
of its divisiveness because of the era
that america was in because it was an
election year
you just had no period of unity
and i was struck state by state you know
some states
life was going on for better or worse as
if the covid
uh coronavirus didn't exist and other
states you know um
you were told off if you weren't wearing
your mask in the street
um so and it seemed to be along
political lines
and i can appreciate that it is but i
also lament that in a way because
it would be good if america could even
have a pandemic that
reminded americans that they're in it
together
in some way and you just you can't even
do that and may i add by the way one
other thing
the one that worries me most now about
your country is this
i think the the the worry people have
had which is that people in america
imbibing different
information streams is a kiddie worry
compared to the real compared to the
real one you've now got
the real one we've now got is you don't
any longer agree as a nation on what you
just
saw that
is terrifying so so that is absolutely
terrible i've been describing that as
the reality war
that that that is this isn't about the
cultural battle this isn't about the
political battle those are those are
battles those are
you know sort of small battles but it's
all framed by the reality war which is
nobody agrees and even in you know we're
holding this
this interview for just two or three
days the amount of stuff that
could change in two or three days even
is crazy but you know when you mention
the sort of
the way we do lockdowns i'm reminded we
went out for for lunch a different day
and we were sitting in that little strip
mall area where we we ordered from one
restaurant and you wanted a cup of
coffee
or you wanted a cappuccino or something
but we were sitting outside of starbucks
which was closed
but they told us we couldn't get coffee
because starbucks owns the strip mall
and wouldn't allow them to serve
coffee even though the starbucks was
closed like that's the level
of insanity that we're dealing with at a
micro level
well you know it to a great extent the
krona era has allowed lots of bossy
people to do the stuff they like the
most
i mean uh there are some people who love
to
you know you can notice it in certain
establishments that are open uh
there are certain people who just won't
do things and you ask why
they say because of corona
there were quite a lot of establishments
so i think it was john cleese who said
famously after doing uh faulty towers at
the definition of a bad hotel or
restaurant
was one run was one run entirely for the
comfort of the staff
um and there are quite a lot of
establishments i think unwisely for
their future
uh uh which of airlines and lots of
other things which are doing lots of
things that are quite
comfortable for the staff but make
things extra unpleasant for the
for the clientele but um no the the
bigger
the bigger problem you have is
is you just can't agree on anything you
didn't agree on the virus
and uh didn't agree on any response to
it and now we have
absolutely ground zero of this problem
can i by the way say very quickly
there's only one there's only one other
thing of similar gravity i've
seen in a developed democracy which is a
very small thing that a lot of people
didn't take any notice of at the time
but it's two years ago
in a town called chemnitz in germany uh
there was a a a video released by
actually
as it happened an antifa account that
had just cropped up could well have been
a disinformation account nobody quite
knows
it showed some uh german-looking men
and some migrant-looking men and the
account said that it was a migrant
hunt that was happening it was a very
serious thing had there been a stabbing
and
by a by a migrant of a local only a few
days earlier
tensions in the area were very high this
video was released by an anonymous
account and by hours after the release
of the video the german chancellor
angela merkel
said publicly we cannot allow this the
hunting of human beings in germany
the reason i tell you this story is
because of this
the head of the domestic intelligence
service in germany
said publicly no it doesn't show that
george mason the man who was the most
important the head of the domestic
intelligence service disagreed with the
chancellor
he said no it's not that
now there's a dispute he is actually was
dismissed from his post
that week now exactly i wrote about at
the time i said look
irrespective of the details or exactly
what it is that's going on
this should be a real warning moment
because we've
we haven't had a we've had a case where
people disagree about how you interpret
or sources and all sorts of things but
for the chancellor and the head of the
intelligence service
to disagree over a piece of footage is
very
very worrying then we come to 2020 in
america
more than eight out of ten trump voters
in the last poll i saw believe donald
trump won the election
and obviously joe biden's voters believe
he won
this seems to me a very perilous moment
for democracy
it's what i just described in chemnitz
on a national
level you saw the same thing
and you've come away with different
conclusions what do you think would be a
responsible way
for the media to talk about this then
because one of the things i've been
trying to do for the last couple weeks
here is i'm saying look
i i don't know exactly what happened i
don't think anyone really knows
i do know that at about midnight pacific
time here that about eight states that
trump had healthy leads in
all stopped voting at the same exact
time i'm not saying trump won
we'll you know now it's gonna go to the
courts and there's all sorts of things
happening
but i've at least been trying to to talk
about it
respectfully right so that it allows
people to say okay let the process
work and then at the end if it comes out
that yes did i want trump
to win yes but if if the courts look
look at everything and he doesn't win
then so be it but i think what a lot of
people are frustrated that
eight out of ten you just referenced i
think what they're seeing
is that the media won't even let you
talk about it and that if you talk about
it you're going to be put on a list
and you're going to be labeled a
conspiracy theorist and you're going to
get booted from social media
and the rest of it and that strikes me
as more of a problem maybe than
what actually happened at some level
no i i disagree with that i mean i think
the biggest
problem is if the president doesn't
leave the white house
and he's lost oh well of course if we
get
there and he and he has actually lost of
course
i mean you know look i'm i'm sympathetic
to much of
your argument on this and your point of
view on this but i mean
and i by the way i'm particularly irate
about the fact that
there are so many democrats who spent
four years claiming that the american
voting system had been fundamentally
undermined and indeed that the russians
have stolen the 2016 election something
for which they never showed us any
evidence
but they asserted anyway nancy pelosi
literally said that
that it was an illegitimate election i
mean yeah
i'm i'm irate about that i was irate
about it for four years i'm irate about
the fact that these same people now
pretend that there is no such thing as
voter fraud in america
however the onus at this stage is on
donald
trump and his legal team to prove
that he won the election now i have to
say i've paid fairly close attention to
this as i say i mean
i first of all may i say the thing of
going to bed and the result being
different when you wake up is
is not unheard of in elections i mean in
the brexit vote
lots of people went to bed thinking that
um
uh that britain was going to remain in
the european union i remember it very
clearly
and of course then suddenly the results
from sunderland and elsewhere in the
north of england came through and
wash we were out and the same people
woke up the next morning amazed
but that's what happened sometimes in
elections um
i do think that donald trump uh is
behaving reprehensibly at the moment i
think that
frankly i am very open for
any and all explanations of voter fraud
as it is going on in america
as it has gone on i think whoever is
president
on january the 20th as a point of
absolute
urgency should put together a
bipartisan non-partisan cross parties
ante
to look into voter fraud specifically
mail in voter fraud in the united states
of america
you cannot have another election after
this one which would be a third in a row
where people didn't believe the results
if they lost
so it seems to me a real point of
urgency this
but on election night when donald trump
came out in the early hours of the
morning and said
um i believe we've already won
we've won as far as i'm concerned he
said i gasped
i gasped i thought oh hell
and there's several things about that
one is
you better if you're the trump team you
better provide really good
fast about that and frankly
what they've provided is not good enough
proof yet
they have been providing uh
some things that sound to me like they
are conspiracy theories unless they've
got a lot of stuff to come i hope that
for their sake they've got a lot of
stuff to come or there are a lot of
reputations that are being trashed
all the time well that's what i've said
from b1 it's like sydney powell she's
either self-immolating in front of us
or she's about to break the greatest
story in in the history of modern times
it's it's one or the other right
yeah i suspect it's the first
uh and i think the same with rudy
giuliani you
you just can't give press conferences
talking about dead venezuelan leaders
and think the citizenry should
i mean it's not just you shouldn't treat
the citizenry stupidly you should not
mislead people's belief in the most
fundamental thing
in our nations which is that we vote and
some people win and some people lose and
you know
who's lost and who's won this is a
really
dangerous thing this is a dangerous
element to be playing with
and and i worry deeply about the
consequences of this
but another thing to point out about
this is
that you know i mean you everyone has to
lose sometimes i remember
michael barone saying this to some
conservative gathering
as one sat many years ago i think when
obama won you know michael brown said
you know you have to lose sometimes um
you know the evidence so far seems to be
that the republican the nominee
for the presidency lost this time now
here's here's the kicker if i may say so
yeah
for four years the question
one of the questions has been why has
donald trump not been able to
recruit now there have been some very
remarkable people who have worked for
him and i
wouldn't do down any of them i'm
thinking of people i think secretary of
state mike pompeo
um uh uh elliot abrams and others
some very very serious particularly
foreign policy figures who have worked
for them who i deeply admire
but there has been a question throughout
the trump presidency why
can he not appear to get
more people working with him
more experienced people working for him
older hands
more trusted figures some non-family
would be nice
uh uh and so on and so forth what is the
explanation and i
you know it's one of those political
questions that ends up answering itself
it's because everyone worried that at
the end of the run
he would pull some crap like this that
was why
that was why i spoke to a lot of people
in recent years in america and
said to them you know an american
friends and said you know
would you consider taking this post why
didn't you consider taking that role and
i always noticed that
some of them you know early on and i
would say you know he's got four years
in office
it's not nothing to be whatever position
was being discussed
and i noticed always this reticence i
think neil ferguson on your show
said that there was always this risk
that trump was going to do something or
come down
in a way that was a scandal of nixon not
only nixonian proportions but that would
make nixon look like you know a sort of
uh tea party no tea party means
something else yeah that means something
else does
not a british tea party well yeah yeah
and and i think that's um i think
that what we are seeing at the moment
may be
the answer to that question i have seen
it once else in politics
in european continental politics with a
much more minor political figure
who the same question was why can't
people cohere around
why don't people trust and in the end
the answer
answered itself because he was going to
in the end
pull the crazy crap he pulled and
and i i just i i think that
less unless the trump team can very very
swiftly
provide evidence that is very good and
persuasive
they are playing with an element that
they should not be playing with
and i think it will it will
deeply diminish the republican party if
it allows it to go on it will diminish
conservatives it will diminish
the millions and millions of decent
american voters who were trying to send
a very distinct message in 2016
who were reviled for four years insulted
for four years called every imaginable
name
for four years it will further
demoralize them and weaken them i
i i hope i hope if he has something it
comes out fast by the way douglas you
know while i'm obviously sympathetic to
to the campaign and i wanted him to win
i'm completely with you on that it's
like if if there isn't anything there
and they
and they've truly done something here
that was to destroy the system or
completely erode trust or anything else
yeah
then it's almost the most dangerous
thing well i guess it would be the
second most dangerous thing
you know compared to actually rigging
the election so
you know we'll find out over the next
couple weeks if they have if they if the
democrats did actually break the
election then it is indeed one it is the
most appalling crime against american
democracy
and there should be a such a thorough
investigation and so many people going
to prison
it would be the scandal of our lifetimes
but if it isn't the case if it isn't the
case
then it is also a great scandal because
you cannot lie to the citizenry about
this i mean
i'm very i'm very open to the argument
of you know four years ago hillary
clinton didn't really
admit that she lost the election and
spent years pretending she had only lost
the election because of the russians and
something to do with a box
on facebook uh look i thought that was
contemptible
i think hillary clinton was again
playing with fire to do her the one
piece of credit that one can do
at least she didn't actually tunnel into
the oval office and barricade herself in
it
after the election in 2016. it's the one
thing hillary clinton has going for her
at the moment yeah
that's that is the one thing i i suppose
um i thought maybe we could shift this a
little bit to the uk
and kind of talk about maybe some
parallels or
just complete differences to what you
guys have going on so you know i've been
talking about this for a long time but
sort of
that all everything we've discussed here
has sort of led to the destruction
of of liberalism in the united states
that we don't really have
many liberals left i would say the few
we have
actually at this point are are basically
conservatives you guys have a different
a different
version of that right like do you do you
think that's for some reason
maybe the history of your country that
you're the age of your country
that liberals have been able to remain
liberal without going completely off the
deep end or
is it maybe that your labor party has
just gone so bananas
that it it allowed the liberals to see
it a little quicker or something
how about some of that i should point
out that
the labour party is in the process of
trying to de-banana
the first the first ever usage of that
one but they just let corbin back in
right after a
two-month uh smackdown or something into
it
shorter they allowed him back into the
party that's right
uh they found that uh uh although he had
been anti-semitic uh throughout his life
uh they found that uh a small slap on
the wrist for anti-semitism turns out to
be fine
so when people said never again what
they meant was
uh suspend you from the party for about
a week which is it's good
it's good to know but but but can you
sort of compare that to what's happened
with our left and democratic party and
what's going on with the labor party
because i think there's some lesson to
be learned there
uh yes i mean our labour party became
unelectable because it uh nominated the
most
unelectable far-left candidate to be the
leader of the party a totally shambolic
morally and physically shambolic and
mentally shambolic man called jeremy
corbyn
a lifelong history of crankery
and you've got to think of
bernie sanders without the charm
and with a good dose of anti-semitism
thrown in
um and you've got something
approximating jeremy corbyn not a lot of
charm with bernie
but i'll go with you the uh the point
was inlaid
anyone's walking around going that
bernie sanders is pretty charming
yeah um but uh um
yes so so they ran really far to the
left
and uh made themselves totally
unelectable and as a result the
conservatives
won an 80-seat majority of the election
in uh december
a majority they've spent their time
squandering it seems to me ever since
but the conservative party in the uk
always lets you down
um and uh and yes but
i think there are some parallels i
wouldn't say that there's a greater sort
of degree of
real liberalism true liberalism in the
great in the great sense in the uk
i think we have the same problems that
you have in different doses um
we have the problem of the media
uh particular left-wing media and the
predominance of it but we've got very
good
conservative media right-leaning media
in the uk from the broad sheets to the
tablets
something i thought about actually in
the us i think i was i was talking about
it with somebody i can't remember who it
was i might say
they referred i said in passing i said
look i i write for every major british
newspaper
and it's a great honor and i i'm you
know and they said do you think it would
be the same if you're in america
and i said actually that's an
interesting question i don't know it
would be actually
because it seems to me that something
very wrong has happened with your media
uh not just the broadcast media but the
print media uh
it's it's um i don't get stuck on it but
i mean
every country i know about i know the
new york times and can prove that it's
lying
so i can't read it because any country i
don't know very much about
i would i would assume that they're
lying but i wouldn't know exactly how
um so so you've got a very
deep problem in your legacy media
and uh obviously a lot of people have
been pointing that out for a long time
um and i wonder now if if trump does go
uh those those papers and magazines will
be in want of an enemy
and uh often as you know that's that's
the worst thing for a person is if they
lose their enemy
um but yes we we we don't have that many
problems
the the the problem we do all have it
seems to me and you've written about
this as
you know about it as well as anyone is
that people have become very bad at
listening to a country opinion
and that is i think that's going to
prove to be a generational thing
that there just is i speak 24 hours
after
the news came out of jordan peterson's
publishers in canada that they've been
wailing gnashing of teeth actual tears
tears
at the at the staff meeting when some
some employees of uh it's painful
uh penguin random path uh uh the the the
some of the employees of penguin
discovered that they were gonna
uh publish another book uh next year by
a man who's actually earned them their
salaries
um quite literally by the way he sold
probably about seven million copies last
i heard so he
floats in many ways the entire ability
for them to
to choose all these other books that
aren't going to do quite as well
yeah yeah it's only because of him that
they can publish the sort of
intersectional fictional
team list um yeah no these um
but this these people we keep hearing
from
uh who uh chase barry weiss out of the
new york times
who chased suzanne moore out of the
guardian in the uk
uh who uh who cry when they learn that a
new jordan peterson book is going to be
published and pay their salary the next
year
this is a generational thing and i don't
know at this stage that we can
say it's completely a political movement
it's some kind of counter-revolution
that has been going on
it believes as you know that speech is
harm
and harm is not harm but silence is
violence and violence is fine
it has a set of mantras and i simply
think it won't
stop until it it hits
the reality of this life i don't know
when that'll happen i just hope it
happens
very very soon i think that everybody
who cried
at the meeting i said this this morning
on social media everybody who cried at
the meeting and said that they didn't
want to be at the publishing house that
published jordan peterson
bang out next morning your job is
advertised so many smart young men and
women
should be in the publishing business and
have it and have a very
very good reason to be so and could be
excellent in their chosen profession
and they're not because these people who
have no right to be in a publishing
house are in it
and and and clogging up and making
everyone stupider
and so the these people there has to be
fun
we have to make sure that media
companies and others are not held
hostage
by the stupidest youngest most ignorant
people in the room
but is the biggest problem there that
these companies once they fall under the
spell i mean you wrote a book about this
but once they fall under the spell they
bring in the diversity and inclusion
department
their hr department is teaching people
to watch out for white supremacism and
all of these things
thus they they destroy their own
entities i'm completely
with you and and i run businesses if i
had employees that were
upset with me over my decision making
goodbye goodbye that's it
you know but but isn't that the the
bigger problem that once you've let this
thing in
in many ways you're the people you're
the very people you'll let the bad guys
in and now they're in the house running
around yes
and what can you do well what you can do
is to reassert your rights as an adult
what i see everywhere in america in
particular is the
complete retreat of the adults let me
give you an example
i'm sure you've heard many times i
thankfully nobody has actually said it
to my face
or they'd have it coming to them but i
have heard a lot of people
told in recent years educate yourself
everybody who says educate yourself
in my observation is without exception
the
dimmest person i have seen speaking
they have no right to go around
being the stupidest person in the room
telling
everyone else to educate themselves they
don't
mean educate yourself they mean agree
with me
or else well here's a suggestion the
adults
say no you do not know
anything you're 23 you've got a
totalistic view of the universe that
you're going to discover
quite soon at some point in your life is
wildly wrong
and you are making yourself unemployable
here
is your unemployment form your jobs up
for advert tomorrow that's what the
adults have to do
i'm fed up by the way of sea of sorts
ceos and
heads of companies and all sorts of
things that ever since the madness of
crowds came out
i find that they sidle up to me they
whisper up to me and tell me that this
is what they have
and i'm fed up with the whisperers and
the seidlers
i'm fed up with the adults the people at
the tops of their careers
all of whom are bowing down it's like
that video that went viral the other day
of this you saw this weird lgbtqia
possible kidney thing yeah yeah the kid
base yeah they're literally
they're bowing down and worshipping the
new
god thing which is
the stupidest person in the room
and i'm not up for the opportunity cost
societally that that involves
um and i think nobody else should be
either
and i'm i'm fed up of the grousing i'm
fed up conservatives grousing about it
but this is the stuff that
we've been talking about for years so it
is nice you
you you and i and many other people we
write books about these things we
we can write columns we can do shows
about it and all of that stuff and then
we get what i think
you just said is the most frustrating
part which is people at companies
and people in their own private lives
who are just still
simply afraid to do anything so then
they'll oh douglas i love your book
but i don't want to take a picture with
you or you know something like that like
you're you're still
too out there and too scary that that in
many ways is the
is the most frustrating part don't you
think
uh well i think they usually love photos
no they just don't want to post them on
facebook
what i find is uh that
they don't realize that what they are
what they are bringing in is mental and
moral asbestos
they don't realize that it's toxic to
everyone in the atmosphere who has to
breathe it
the job of the adults is to strip the
moral and
mental asbestos from the building as
fast as
possible and if that means stripping
a whole load of under 30s out then
fine there are a lot of very smart under
30s
who could fill those positions and would
do a great and nobler job at it
but it is absolutely incumbent upon
people
as you know it's what i argue in the
madness of crowds to understand
that that is what we are dealing with
once you play the diversity and equity
game
you are infusing the lungs
of your employees with this asbestos
and you have to get it out now
can i just say that uh before we finish
here that you're in particularly fine
form today douglas murray
i'm getting particular i'm getting
particularly sharp douglas murray
douglas murray's always sharp but but
we're
we're really we're really getting it
today i'm not i'm not always sharp
i want to back up early i want to back
up though because look i have a sharpie
in my hand and i actually scribbled
something down that you said then i
didn't want to lose it
because you said conservatives always
let you down
and i'm in the midst of and i think a
lot of people feel that right now
there's especially a feeling amongst the
trump side of things that oh
if he loses i'm done with conservatives
because we're just going to get these
sort of
limp wristed people you know we'll get
these mitt romney types who will just
really sort of be democrats
cloaked as republicans or something like
that
but i'm watching the crown on netflix
right now
and in the current season it uh is
very heavily involved with margaret
thatcher
and i just bought uh one of her
biographies because
every word that comes out of this
woman's mouth in this show
seems right to me she talks about the
cowardice she talks about the
establishment
she talks about leaders who must do
unpopular things
and the rest of it um i'm not even sure
what my question is there
other than conservatives will always let
you down that's what you said before and
you guys have your own version of it
but there are occasionally leaders that
don't let you down right
at least for a certain amount of time of
course
of course um the reason i say
i mean the conservative party in the uk
lets us down repeatedly it's very bad at
defending its friends
it's very bad it's standing up for its
own it tends to
uh give up principle we've got one at
the moment where
there's a sort of awful feeling that
boris johnson the postcovered era
is going to basically try to save the
whale and not much else um
you know as if as if conservatives were
anti-whales
before as if we as if we used to have
meetings in darkened rooms
discussing how the oceans should be
cleansed of these magnificent creatures
you know there's a sort of
there's a sort of let's do the thing
people don't think conservatives would
do
sort of thing and that will persuade
them we're good you then also have that
phenomenon you mentioned mitt romney
you have that phenomenon in america
where once the conservative has been
castrated by the left
the left side oh yes yes
the moment the moment that an american
republican
becomes a eunuch the left says how sexy
they are
you saw this never clearer than with
john mccain
i remember when john mccain was being
described as a reprehensible
racist bigoted old
warmonger much more i saw this with
goodness knows i mean we saw it with
mitt romney you see it with george w
bush
and he's not trump i i
i fought quite a lot of battles in the
george w
bush era explaining that there were
still some things that were good america
about america and i remember the wild
demonization of bush and i'm just old
enough to remember some of the wild
demonization of ronald reagan
yes this is something that happens to
conservatives and there is a tendency
then for the conservative
after the point of utility or after the
battle to suddenly seek some kind of
sucker from the enemy camp
margaret thatcher never did that never
did that
i've been watching i've watched the
crown by the way as well by the way
appalling anti-monarchy
it's so anti-the queen it's appallingly
rude
and and and uh misleading against
multiple members of the royal family
and i actually think by the way that it
is really rather anti-margaret thatcher
they show her to be much more um i mean
they show her for instance if she didn't
know how to behave when she visits
balmoral
and and much more she was a much more
remarkable figure than
she is shown to be in the series so i'm
delighted that you think she came across
well
for the record i'm only because she was
even i'm only about halfway
she was even better i'm only about
halfway through
this season and also at the same time
i've been following this margaret
thatcher account on twitter where they
put up
her actual clip so this isn't just well
she was
she was a remarkable uh figure i have
all sorts of criticisms as everybody
does of any politician but
but uh she was a remarkable figure and a
product of
a quite remarkable once in a generation
figure by the way
there's something important about this
which is yes she had backbone because
she had
she had it from a sense of purpose and
drive and moral belief from the
beginning
but also to some extent in the charles
moore biography brings this out
she also found herself into thatcherness
as she was being prime minister which is
a very important thing
the people do grow into jobs that they
are in
they learn by experience just as some
people give in
so so others become more resolute
margaret thatcher was a great example of
that by the
by the way at the end she was brought
down by small men and some of those
small men michael hesselthein for
instance
uh a preening former politician in the
uk
keeps popping up now to berate the uk
over brexit he keeps popping up as if he
will ever be remembered
for anything other than a spitting
vicious latter era where he attacked the
british people
for their vote and for one other thing
which was forgetting margaret thatcher
out
of power and that is not a great legacy
it seems to me
but there were these small men all
around her and i think
yes it was a tendency in a british
conservatism then
as it is an american conservatism and it
is to some extent now
to always try to just do the easier
thing and what it meant always what it
means always
is that the left comes up with a wildly
radical proposition
and the right decides to meet them
halfway between
the center and the far left and margaret
thatcher knew
always no that is not what a
conservative does
i would love to see by the way a change
around i'm fed up with the with the as i
said before the winding and the carping
of conservatives across the pond
and in britain i'm fed up with people
who present themselves always on the
back foot not least because who would
want to join a movement
that was forever moaning about itself
people like margaret thatcher
should remind people of the nobility
and the strength of good right wing
arguments and they should people should
go to them
as a resource and an inspiration to
realize what true
moral leadership consists of you know i
sense that's probably
a little more difficult although uh
the right thing to do i sense it's a
little more difficult than just being
liked
you know like that sort of that's sort
of what happens that the conservative
things
she walked through fire she walked
through fire on everything
the economics by the end of her last of
her first term
it was not clear that the economics were
going to turn in her favor as they did
but she knew that she was right and she
dragged the country
from a position of serious trouble in
the 1970s
into the country that she left us when
she left office
all right douglas now i'm gonna do the
impossible with you which is
i think i've done this with you once or
twice before to end interviews actually
but but spin me the version that that
makes 2021
a little better than 2020 a little
saner whether you believe it or not
what's what's a map
that could kind of get us to something
that we could all feel a little better
about
or would be a little less worrying
relative to all the things we've talked
about here is there such a map
well all of us hope of course 2021 is
nothing like 2020.
my own uh views on 2020 have been
that we all have one principal job
which is to not go insane
that's not nothing but the job of not
becoming deranged
by the way little anecdote but
everywhere i went in america
when i saw people who are old friends
sometimes sometimes new friends
every dinner table i sat at there was an
explosion at some point
it's not good it's not good it didn't
used to be like that
i think i think we kept i think we kept
ours to a minimum but that that might
have been the gin
actually i should have said except for
the evening of
reuben um
i i think apart from yes maybe apart
from that
i just was amazed by the way in which
what used to be ordinary conversations
uh would just exploded uh
and i think that's because and i say
this at the end of matters of crowds as
you know which is that people
have over politicized their lives
politics is exceptionally important and
i take a great interest in it as you do
and i know
i know how much it does affect and
change the lives of people it's not a
game
that said it's a very unwise
thing to put all of your personal stock
in
and i feel that a younger generation in
particular has been misled
into thinking they will find purpose and
all the meaning of life
in political activism politics always
lets you down just like conservatives
always let you down
they always let you down politicians at
some point
and so it would be a very unwise thing
on any estimation to put all of your
happiness on a
senate race or congress or midterms or a
presidential election
very important things though these are i
hope that people don't whatever
happened in the coming weeks i hope they
don't turn off politics
but i hope that people get a better
estimation of them
and i hope one thing above all if i may
say so for the united states
the united states is an extraordinary
moment in its history
because it's clear that there is a war
on the american past
and if that war is successful in
demoralizing the american people into
thinking not
let's have a reasonable estimation of
our past as any country should
but we will always awful
if that succeeds then there's nothing
good that america
can ever do because it was always rotten
i think there's a lot of good that
america has done throughout her history
i think there's an enormous amount that
america can do
for good in the years ahead but for that
to happen
there has to be some better
understanding and reckoning with your
past
because you are now at the stage where
you could as a nation
be overtaken by the one country
the one country whose gdp is expected
to rise this year which is china
i would submit to anybody who doesn't
like the era of american dominance and
there are things to be said against it
as there are many things to be said for
it
just imagine the world you would inherit
if this goes wrong if america goes the
way of
portland and seattle and other
immigrated
places if it cannot find pride in itself
if it loses its sense of drive and
purpose and if the american people
fall for this negative version of their
history this is an incredibly important
axis that the world is currently turning
on
and as somebody on the edges of the
american empire
it matters as much to me as it does to
very many of you at the very heart of it
douglas there's nobody better thanks for
thanks for taking the time i know you're
in the midst of travels
and you got a lot going on we will link
to madness of crowds i'm sure everybody
has it already
uh you're in second print already right
uh updated edition even better right up
to date
uh yeah nice i'm i'd like to think way
past second printing i mean
second
new material new gags new insults
it's all there all right thank you my
friend i look forward to seeing you
whether it's on this side of the pond
that side of the pond we'll figure it
out
much look forward to it thank you if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell